merry christmas eve everyone thanks so
much for joining us tonight at 11
i'm bianca holman families across the
valley are finding
new ways to celebrate the holiday in
light of the coronavirus
including those directly impacted by it
oracle mana shares
the story of one family and they
describe this as
one christmas miracle christmas is
always a time to spend with family
but amid covid19 loved ones are holding
each other a little tighter this year
one valley family tells me after
battling the virus
they're just grateful they can celebrate
the holiday we try to be enjoy
every moment because as is as hard for
a lot of people martin palomino is
counting his blessings this christmas
martine
his wife irene and their two kids are
now fully recovered after they all
tested positive for covid19 about a
month ago
i feel like kind of like a fever say
and my body starts to be you know like
achy body
like you know chills irene tells me
things turned around just in time for
the holidays but there are some
lingering effects
i still having a little coughing once in
a while but i think it's part of that
i'm not contagious anymore we are
healthy right now
like many hispanic families in las vegas
christmas is extremely important to
martine
and irene they've decked their halls
making them merry
and bright they're even cooking up a
christmas turkey with classic peruvian
spices and although this year isn't the
large celebration it usually is
they're just happy they can enjoy this
holiday together
we're really blessing and thankful to
them it's a christmas miracle and as our
community continues to combat the
coronavirus
they have a message for all of us
keeping it strong keep positive
help each other martine also wants to
encourage everyone to keep practicing
the basics
hand washing mask wearing and social
distancing
reporting in las vegas orca mana 8 news
now